David Lindsey has many happy memories of
his family holidays I think this is
probably the best picture we have as a
family this was a trip to India a few
years ago it was the family's love of
travel which saw father Matthew take his
daughter
Amelie and middle son Danny on the left
of picture on an Easter trip to Sri
Lanka 21 year old David who stayed in
London to study with his mother and
younger brother says his father survived
by a twist of fate as they were running
they were caught in the in the second
explosion by the accent I think my dad
had literally been a cab in a couple
meters behind behind my sister and my
brother and just from the way that the
blast fell he survived almost untouched
yes he has a few cuts on his face and
he's obviously extremely shaken and
distraught this was 19 year old Danny
Lindsay in Ethiopia where he'd recently
done volunteer work with orphans that
was really what he loved his getting out
of his comfort zone meeting people no
matter what their backgrounds were they
were from who befriend everyone and
everyone he met always loved him he was
he was such a pure soul Danny had wanted
to go to Sri Lanka to see elephants
these are the families pictures that was
her like favorite experience in the
holiday this photograph of Emily was
taken in Vietnam just before they got to
Sri Lanka she was really the glue that
held the family together and all of us
just would still have like an in
description born with her and she's left
unimaginably big shoes to fill and
remember and be very hard to continue
without her the 8th British victim is
Lorraine Campbell pictured at her
wedding last year to husband Neil she
was killed at another hotel her son Mark
said the world had lost someone
beautiful I think people who you know
feel the whole people she touched
remembered her the people who were in a
circle they were family I just think I
think everyone's lost someone
we ate victims from the UK but many
hundreds more being mourned by families
in Sri Lanka and across the world Lisa
Holland Sky News